[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I like to call it dear Jessica and
Hank or as I like to call it dear Edward
and Jessica and that's right you guys is
the first time there's up her three
people on the podcast they stink I think
this is the first time you've ever had
three people at the podcast but in any
case this is the podcast where two
brothers and occasionally a special
guest hosts answer your questions give
you devious advice and bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
London except for that last part isn't
gonna happen today because we're
recording this significantly in advance
and and our guest hosts today are
Jessica and Edward who together produce
and create the YouTube show how to ADHD
about attention deficit hyperactivity
disorder and associated things I'm
really excited to hang out with you guys
again
I've always enjoyed hanging out with you
but this time we're gonna record it the
whole time which is extra weird it's
super weird especially when we're not in
charge of the edit that's weird I
totally recorded it all the first time
wait what well we were in California you
have to tell people you have to tell
people I just told you I just told you I
feel like there's a sort of statute of
limitations on like how long all right
you have to tell me now I have to invent
time travel it's fine it's fine this is
how I start the podcast I ask how are
you doing I I'm good I got to go back to
yoga for the first time cuz I was in a
like a coma from I adopted a puppy like
did six weeks ago and I was like Oh
it'll be a cute thing to have around the
house and I forgot that it's like mostly
teeth and like bladder for the first
month and so I'm finally coming out of
this coma where I'm like I have time for
other things so I got to go yoga today
and I was like Edward you're in charge
of the dog bite I just ran up the door
and it was fantastic I have a great time
just because is it true I think I'm also
finding out what kind of dad I'm gonna
be because Jessica and I are married
obviously but maybe not obviously to
something but yes we are I'm finding out
what kind of dad I'm gonna because when
Jessica takes the puppy out her name is
Chloe she's so like gentle and like hey
we're gonna do this in training and I
just went okay you have to
tired we're running basically ran for
about seven or eight minutes straight
like I would stop to let her catch her
breath and she has tiny legs I mean I
wasn't running I was speed walking at
bed right she was Holly she could which
is hilarious cuz you have very specific
instructions on like what to do yeah I
did not do any of them you said you said
exercise her and feed her and I did
those things awesome you guys literally
took me like several minutes I feel like
I feel like you're gonna be the kind of
dad where I'm like entertain our kid and
I'm gonna come back and you're gonna be
like poker and beer was fine right
what do you mean heroines off the table
yeah you got you can't undo all of the
hard work that Jessica did with this
puppy at one hour at yoga class this is
like textbook parenting right now it's
happening you're learned I know we have
to get on the same page dog seriously
cuz I'm so gonna be like the
disciplinarian and Edwards gonna be the
fun dad and it's gonna suck trying
you just have to care less you have to
care less all right we're gonna do some
questions from our listeners you guys
because I cannot psychoanalyze this just
just this one particular couple we also
have to deal with people who are
actually looking for advice unlike you
who I'm giving it to unprompted oh wait
no no you brought a poem so you should
do a poem I did bring a poem okay so
this I love this poem it's by Emily
Dickinson who by the way was thought to
have not just depression but also
possibly ADHD so this it's called I had
no time to hate because I had no time to
hate because the grave would hinder me
and life was not so ample I could finish
enmity nor had I time the love but since
some industry must be the little toil of
love I thought was large enough for me
oh yeah that's good oh man poetry it did
the thing that poetry is supposed to do
to me it makes me feel a poetry you guys
you guys was that a pope was that a
happening tell me poetry
what did you
what did it make you feel it gave me a
little goosebumps I was like oh yes huh
that is right right I love short love I
love short poems because it's it's
impossible to to cram the the whole of
everything that you want to express in
like eight lines and yet she did it
right like it's so impressive to me like
what you had you had told me about this
one before but like just hearing you
read just now it really did give me
chills I was amazing
maybe maybe I have a career in poetry
reading ADHD thing goes away how to poet
it's the name right so nobody the reason
why I love this poem so much is because
it it really does remind us and like as
a youtuber I have to find myself of this
all the time like you don't you don't
really have time in life to fight with
people and to hate things like it's just
your time here is short so do something
good with it
you know like hate doesn't get anywhere
it just creates more hate right I feel
yeah absolutely and if we're speaking of
having a positive impact on the world
and the time in which we're here we have
a question from Gillian it's a segue you
guys that happened does a stretch tank
I'm not gonna lie Gillian asked dear
Hank and Jessica Edward I am having an
extremely important ethical dilemma when
in the grocery store I look for and buy
produce products with the latest
expiration date available I previously
thought that this was normal and
inconsequential but am i contributing to
product waste or causing people that
shop after me to buy older produce
please help as I may be a horrible
person and do not know it I wish I had a
name specific sign-off but in the
attempt once in a jillion how it works
oh no I love that okay first of all I do
want to normalize this for you because
I'm pretty sure that everybody does this
like everybody goes and looks through
cuz like you have to make sure it's not
expired and then while you're looking
you're like maybe there's one that's
like less they expired or like more not
expired I think it's really normal to do
it but yes it does contribute to product
waste I worked in the restaurant
industry for a lot of years and
like a thing that you have to do which
is first-in first-out so like that's how
things that's how these systems keep
working without breaking down is if is
if whatever is on front that's what you
take however I will give you this
permission if you are going to cook
something and in like five days and you
need this thing to not expire before
then I don't think there's anything
wrong with like taking one behind it but
if you know that you're gonna like I
don't know you're getting milk and
you're gonna use it all today or
tomorrow anyway like take them take the
one that's gonna expire in a few days
and like you know do humanity a favor
but I think that there are certain
circumstances when it's totally fine to
be selfish and look for the look for the
one in back the other thing I gotta say
the jillian is just thinking about this
makes me think you're probably a pretty
good person like you're like putting
this front of mind you're like wait wait
what is the effect that my like
seemingly inconsequential decision is
going to have on the world at large just
the fact that you had that thought makes
me think you're probably doing okay
exactly no that's a really good point I
think probably most of the people
walking around thinking they're horrible
people are some of the best people on
the planet just because everybody was
actually a horrible person is like I'm
fine with all of this yeah if you're if
you're truly horrible self reflection is
not a symptom of being a terrible person
you can just be like yeah I didn't it
didn't even occur to me that I am just
awful I think I think mostly mostly
people it does not occur to them and
such as life you guys want to ask
another question
alright so Kirsten asks dear Hank and
Jessica I guess and Edward my graduate
school right you're here to my graduate
school requires us all to purchase a set
of business cards at the start of our
program presumably for networking and
that sort of thing either in sets of 250
or 500 I ordered 500 but that turns out
to be a lot of business cards plus I
somehow ended up with a double order so
now I have a thousand business cards my
program is only two years long and at
the rate I've been handing them out
there's not a snowball's chance in hell
I'm gonna use all of these cards I
thought that if anyone had any dubious
ideas about what to do with the thousand
business cards it would be YouTube
thanks for any suggestions you can give
Kirsten
three just so oh yes you you're still
here once upon a time in the history of
vlogbrothers I actually had this exact
problem I well very similar I
accidentally got my business cards
printed with the same thing on the front
and back and it was just the logo of my
company my name was not on them anywhere
and so I turned to the audience said hey
what should I do with all these printed
business cards and I got a bunch of
ideas I taped them to my face I made
little origami things out of them and
then ultimately like you could also just
I could I was like oh I could just stamp
my name and number on them and turn them
into actual business cards that's not
gonna help
Kirstin here whoo gosh how like how long
does it take to even meet a thousand
people
yeah depends on if you're introverted
you pose like it would take me quite a
while
i I okay assuming that she can't go
through these thousand business cards in
the two years I just I vote you still
use them they're still good just crossed
out the listing is a candidate in the
program and replace it with I don't know
either what you are now or if you want
to have fun with it and replace it with
things like space alien or professional
dog putter or promoter because you like
the color purple and you think there
should be more purple in the world and
then even better like awesome all out at
the same party until everybody's really
confused
wait I love I love love love the idea
that the color purple has like an
association and right it's like this is
not its own movie just so well this
right right I forgot this this mess this
movie brought to you by the purple
Association of America we just didn't
think there was enough purple so we
started an organization you know there's
advocacy for all kinds of things Hank
whatever you think is important and
there should be more of in the world
like you can be an advocate for that you
could do an advocate of grilled cheese
sandwiches I just I just realized that
if you did hand those things out and
with the scratch that thing with
something else to the to the viewer it
would seem as though you'd have a
drastic change in career
get so it's still visible whatever it
was before the whole thing didn't the
whole that whole graduate school thing
did not work out I am now a space alien
I mean that's pretty much what people do
when they go to college for one thing
and then like they I caught it with that
out and like you have a replacement
agree with whatever they end up doing
with their life and I mean how can one
become a professional pet Petter because
I do like that activity and if someone
wanted to pay me I probably would accept
that I would accept that you know I
think you just start putting it on
business cards and handing it out until
there's somebody like me who has a puppy
that's like can somebody else pet her
for a while and whatever you charge like
I will pay it I will just do it like I
will put her on a plane right now what
is the puppy doing right now she's
snoozing on my lap she's being so sweet
no she's got one eye open she's like I
know what's up I know what's going but
yeah she's snoozing on my lap and like
anticipating treats so it's like every
every every 30 seconds or so she gets a
tiny piece of string cheese for being
good yeah yeah no it's not bribing
there's actually a really fundamental
difference so when you're training a dog
you have to make sure that like you ask
them to do the thing and then they do
the thing and you give them a reward
here's the difference
bribing is us them do you think they're
like go screw yourself and then you pull
out the treats and you're like now will
you do it and then that's bribing them
and that's not that's not good same for
kids by the way know you're learning a
lot it seems to me like you're the kind
of person who who's going to be a good
at things because you seem to have that
attitude of I'm gonna do a bunch of
research and I'm gonna do this all
correctly shoes oh yeah I feel like
anybody in this day and age can be good
at anything just because Google exists
like you can look it up I wrote a song
I've never written a song in my life and
I had barely started playing the ukelele
and I'm like hey wikiHow how do I write
a song and wikiHow was like I'll tell
you in fourteen steps and I did the
steps and I wrote a song like you wanna
tell people you should have told them
that it was a wikiHow production I can't
believe we didn't mention this is
brought to you by wikiHow yeah the whole
podcast or your song in particular you
know
now is it a wiki down dog Nidhi sorry
Hank we sold sponsorship on the podcast
I hope that's I thought that was assumed
that's that's I mean that's one way of
doing it well bring out our special
guests and they get a little bit of
benefit from it they bring their own
sponsors it's great okay this one was
unsigned dear Hank and Jessica and
Edward my husband and I are average
income people with a house and kid my
grandparents are retired and have a bit
of money when it comes to time for
gift-giving occasions they always ask me
what I won they don't like giving gift
cards because they say that's not a gift
but I don't need anything in particular
we have all the decorations clothes
candles etc that we might need what is
helpful would be a Target gift card for
diapers and groceries a home depot gift
card for home repairs or somewhere else
I can get useful things how do I explain
to them without offending them or
seeming like we're broke
signed anonymous I mean they're so there
are certain things that now John is
gonna if John were here he would jump in
immediately and say gifts are terrible
and economically inefficient there are
certain household necessities that can
kind of be have become GiftA fide I'm
thinking specifically of soap you can
never really have enough soap because
soap eventually will get used and it
will be gone and for some reason soap
has become an artisanal craft work that
you can get at an admittedly elevated
price but that at least is used and that
at the end of the process is gone and no
longer in your house that's the key
right so stays in business no no the key
the key is to ask for things that like
will get used and then no longer stay in
your house because if you if you have
like even three friends and like you
have birthdays and Christmases like over
the course of 15 years like pretty soon
you have way too much stuff in your
house like so much stuff so yes I'm such
a fan of things that will go away and
yeah can't can't you ask for groceries
or diapers does that just be like I'm
just super into diapers
oh by the way I want to say like
technically so started out artisanal it
was only became mass manufactured later
it originally was all just handmade it
didn't suddenly how come that later
right shoot we're going backwards we are
I have to I have to say this because I
feel so passionately about this gift
cards are a gift gift cards are the gift
of freedom gift cards are a gift that
says you know what I don't know if I
know what you want I don't know if you
know what you want right now but you
know what I'm gonna give you the freedom
to have it later even if it's a five
dollar gift card
it's like you know what this is
something free that I'm gonna be able to
have when it strikes me rather than
whatever you can come up with in those
six days before Christmas or whatever it
might be
I love gift cards and I emphasize
everyone use them and the only catch is
when you use them when you post about
whatever you got make sure you say you
know hey guys was so cool so and so
insert name of person who gave you gift
card got me a insert the name of the
thing that you bought with the guide for
Christmas I think that's the key good I
feel like there's two separate things
that happened inside of your answer
Edward and I like them both okay one
important thing was their called gift
cards grandma their gifts that's why
they call them that and then to you
changed what a thank-you card is and you
didn't even notice it that like and
maybe of course maybe everybody knows
this and maybe this is a recognized
phenomena that I do not know about but
now thank-you cards are super
out-of-date and you would never like
write a note and say thank you so much
for losing no you post about it on
social media you put it on Facebook and
you're like thanks Trevor
for the pants bonus points if you get
something with a gift card that they
would be mortified to know that you
bought with them well I mean maybe don't
do that no Thank You Tori should I
cannot continue this line of discussion
thank you bye nice date like the you're
vegan grandparents give you a gift card
thanks for the Omaha Steaks and they
don't like giving gift cards thank you I
really know what you're gonna do with
him
thanks Trevor for these 1000 pokemon
cards that I bought by the way
apparently Trevor is just quite generous
in your world he's giving you pay no no
yes I don't know how much a thousand
pokemon cards called costs pants aren't
that exciting today's market pretty much
a lot probably depends on I would I
would yeah if you get like the really
rare ones that you probably get a
thousand squirtle you probably get those
just with a printing error see our
earlier answer I deeply agree that gift
cards are great present and also that
you should tell people the thing that
you got with their gift card and well in
some way and be and to thank them but
like it is weird to be in that place
where you're like well you look we need
two diapers and it's really nice to not
have to worry about this particular
diaper payment you could also I mean my
grandparents what a lot of what they
gave my parents was like stock for me or
like invest like bond savings bonds that
kind of thing
and that's like really nerdy and dumb
and I don't know it's a little bit weird
to ask for but I think that that is a
good grandparent gift just to be like I
got you fifty dollars of Apple stock
which it probably is it possible because
Apple stock cost more than 50 dollars a
share or whatever but it's something
like that something that maybe by the
time the kid is 18 years old is gonna be
worth more and will be a lesson and how
investment works yeah it's brilliant if
somebody had bought me Apple stock when
I was a kid like I would be rich I think
that I'm really brilliant think so it's
like yeah it'll be fun either it'll be
worth like a million dollars or nothing
at all like it's a gamble I just it's
like a lottery ticket
I love the idea of asking your
grandparents to give you or your
children stock if they the grandparents
don't already know how stock works like
I get you why chicken stock your name is
like a lot of times I guess if they
really want stock I guess they're
planning on making a soup
give me give me the chicken stuff give
me the chicken stuff vegan grandma I
guess it's back around to me now for
another question this one's from Laura
who asks dear Hank and Jessica and
Edward I turned 16 in just a little
under two months well I'm glad you got
your question in before this actually
happens which means that I have to plan
a birthday party I don't know do you
have to plan it or would someone do that
for you
do you plan your own birthday party I
don't know how this works I feel like
maybe I don't know I don't know the
issue is I don't have enough close
friends to throw a big sweet 16 bash
type thingy and I don't want to invite
more people than I'm close with what are
some birthday party alternatives for
about 15 people that are still fun and
significant enough for a sweet 16
pronounced like croft Laura I think
that's how Laura Croft is pronounced 15
seems like a lot of people to me yeah I
definitely didn't even have 15 friends
total to invite when I turned 16 so
congratulations on being very popular
apparently because you have 15 close
friends yeah depending on where you live
what are those rooms the yes doing an
escape room would be an amazing amazing
birthday party plus then you then you
could know like which friends could help
you if you're really in a jam and decide
which of these 15 friends to take with
you on to college will be making it to
college I love that I love that I have I
have no other ideas I went on for my
birthday once I went to a water park but
I brought three people with me because
that was about as much as I could manage
yeah no that's that's pretty impressive
yeah there's a yeah if nobody's if
nobody's planning this birthday party
for you I would say do what you want to
do like I land so many parties I got
asked my parents to do so many parties
that I was not at all interested in
because I thought it was like what you
should do so at one point I had a party
where my dad hired a DJ and like built a
stage in the backyard like over the
sandbox and I mean we don't have a lot
of money he just like had his
who wanted to be a DJ and like laid some
planks of manoeuvred sandbox but built
the stage is very it's not like up to
code no not at all I think we're glad
that nobody stopped by to check it out
but but I had I had a bunch of friends
and it was a bunch of people that I
wasn't that into and it was like a dance
party and at the time I had no idea how
to dance and not only that I would been
already traumatized because I had gone
from a private school to a public school
where suddenly everybody knew how to
dance and I'd only like read about it in
books turns out not the same at all and
my friends had actually tried to teach
me anyway I ended up mortified in my
bedroom this entire party because
everybody else was out there dancing and
having a good time and I had no idea
what I was doing yeah
so yeah do you something you like that's
that's all I'm gonna say do something
you enjoy you can't do as bad as Jessica
like that's what we've all learned yes
like if she was real she'd be like
sixteen in the room in her room by
herself reading a book like you throw a
party she does not want to dance she has
no interest in beasts to read yeah can I
just have a library for my 16th birthday
like that would've been amazing I'm
still waiting for my library I really
want to I really want a library someday
just a whole room with books this is
this doesn't even have to be for the
podcast I just tell you when we went and
saw the live action version of Beauty
and the Beast what'd the movie one of
the cool things they did that made it
better is they they made the moment when
she starts to realize the beast is cool
when she sees the library like they kind
of did that in the Disney movie but in
the live-action it was like you could
see she was getting into him all of a
sudden yeah cuz it wasn't just the
library it was he had read all the books
brittle and she's like oh my kind of man
yeah okay so I believe it is your turn
yeah because before it was just kind of
a Stockholm Syndrome it was totally a
style cat it's it's pretty creepy story
when you come right down to it it really
is so many children's stories are aren't
they correct the lady and the Beast
Hansel and Gretel I don't understand
like why you would tell that to a five
like don't mother into the woods like
you'll get stuck in an oven yo I gotta
learn not to wander into the woods
there's fairytales used to be about like
you know you tell these things to kids
to to get them back right
I didn't realize that yeah they're not
they're not bedtime stories they're
warnings they are all hornings wow that
just changed my childhood that would be
like if you started reading to your
children at night like caution rocks
[ __ ] me fall ahead like all the or or
maybe some more applicable concern signs
I feel like the next morning of not
spending too much time on social media
yeah exactly this is the kind of bedtime
stories we need we need bedtime stories
about like how dangerous it is to see
your life as a series of quantified
likes and shares and follows on social
media and gretel Ridge regretted posting
all those photos on Instagram that day
this makes me think like kids in the
past we would not fall asleep to these
stories they lay up all night going oh
my god like this could happen to me now
now we're so far removed from that that
it's like oh it's sleep that's true yeah
anyway sorry
that was totally tangential uh Sofia
says dear Hank and Jessica and Edward I
remember to you this time for a long
time I found myself clicking on Facebook
or Instagram when I opened my phone and
then mindlessly scrolling through the
feeds usually this happens when I'm
procrastinating something I actually
need to do but also sometimes I'll
realize that I opened one of these apps
without realizing what I'm doing yeah
vinner i don't enjoy doing this and i
really wish this wasn't something i
instinctively did however I have this
weird part of me that feels a sense of
obligation to remain on these platforms
because I have family members that reach
out to me on them occasionally and I
sometimes use Facebook's Facebook groups
for school related purposes how can I
stop using social media when everything
in my life is seemingly entangled in the
social internet any suggestions as to
how you have dealt with managing time
spent mindlessly scrolling would be
greatly appreciated I have no idea Sofia
I love the honesty they're like I don't
know help somebody else be in charge of
my phone I mean I will literally be on
Reddit and I will type reddit in
to the URL bar I like I'm so broken I'm
so broken what is it like I have like
four or five automatic places to go
Twitter Google News reddit my email
that's mostly it and my my fingers will
do it without me telling them to
sometimes even when I'm already there I
feel like that's like the alcoholic
reaching under the sink and realizing
all the bottles are empty you're like
this is a moment I have just realized
there's something wrong with me and the
first step is admitting that there is a
problem and congratulations on reaching
that step I am I'm not surprised if if
we don't start having 12-step groups for
social media like really soon if they if
they don't already exist but there are
there are things that you can do besides
going cold turkey I okay first of all
there are apps where if you just need to
be off your phone because you're busy
procrastinating on homework or something
that is gonna be obviously less exciting
than anything that you might find on
social media there's an app called
forest where you can plant a tree or a
bush or whatever depending on how long
you want to not be on your phone like 15
minutes 20 minutes or whatever if you
don't need your phone it's great because
it it helps with the mindfulness you
pick up your phone and you realize like
oh right like I was not going to do this
right now I was going to do X whatever
else that I'm gonna work on and you can
switch out of the app where you're busy
growing a tree for 15 minutes but you
will kill your tree if you do so and you
can you can do the version they have a
version where you will actually get to
plant real trees in real life like
you'll be contributing to actually
planting trees in in the real world if
you build enough trees or sorry if you
grow enough trees clearly I'm not a
gardener to build stages and trees just
all kinds of no but it's it's a great
app I really recommend it I think it's
free too cheap I'm not sure exactly but
it's it's really great if you do need to
be on your phone or you do need to check
social media because it is kind of hard
to live without it at this point
I heard the
best tip oh my god this guy had social
media rules for himself or rules about
using his phone in general one was turn
off your notifications like you don't
need those you're gonna remember to
check your Facebook and if you don't
it's not the end of the world you're
gonna remember to check your Instagram
so turn off those notifications and then
when you go on to when you go onto your
phone under your social media to check
things do one round and don't repeat it
go through your Facebook your Instagram
your Twitter whatever you do once and
then don't go and start the whole cycle
over again and see if like anybody liked
your posts since you posted it like 10
minutes ago go you know go away do
something else for a while like come
back in an hour and you can do the
rounds again but it does amazingly keep
you from just spending the whole day on
social media if you only go through the
rounds once I want to add a tip to that
actually one other thing that is really
super helpful I read an article once
about how to make your phone less
appealing because I had the exact same
problem they said other than things like
turn off your notifications stuff like
that they said you can do this in your
settings in the accessibility settings
for most phones turn it to black and
white
that's so hardcore I can't do it when
you turn it to black and white your eyes
just you just don't care like like your
eyes are not the color it is no longer
drawing you in so Justin's like copy and
you kind of lose interest
it just it gets boring very quickly and
you can just kind of go well yeah let's
do something else that feels weird that
like the that we're just like ooh candy
this is everything
candy crush did so well there's another
one by the way I haven't checked it out
yet but somebody else told me about it
called rocket focus so you can actually
build rockets instead of planting trees
but I think it works kind of the same
way but I think I think on that when
it's only 25 minutes so it's based on
the Pomodoro Technique where for 15
minutes or 20 minutes 25 minutes
whatever period of time you only do what
you mean to do you don't you don't do
anything else you don't answer a phone
call you don't answer texts you don't
check your email you don't do anything
except the task you're intending to work
on and then you get a five minute break
and it can help so much because it was
so like
so many of our tasks take like 10 times
the amount of time that they should take
just because we constantly are
interrupting with other tasks and you
have to switch gears and for some of
this movement is especially with ADHD
those transitions are really difficult
yeah and I think it's like it's
absolutely the case that a lot of these
things we cannot remove from our lives
it's very important part of how we
socialize how we stay in contact with
family and friends and also a very
important part of work even if you don't
work on the internet the way that we do
just it's part of networking and part of
being able to know what other people in
your industry are doing so you you need
to be on Facebook and it's too bad
because I think a lot of people would
rather not honestly and figuring out how
to use it just for the things that you
need to use it for while not doing the
sort of things that it is designed to
suck you into doing and as you were
saying I have a huge problem where I
when I post something I have this sudden
like existing recurring thought loop
that's like you should check and see
what the responses to that were make
sure that there aren't any problems or
you didn't say anything wrong or see how
many people liked it and see if it's
doing well and then I'm back in the feed
again
breaking out of that yeah not easy you
get the little dopamine hits every time
somebody likes it or retweets it or
whatever so like they can actually
become addicting in that sense but but I
have seen the occasional you dude post a
tweet and I'm like huh I guess that's a
word that I just didn't know and then
like the next day you'll be like no that
was completely not a word I was totally
falling asleep hank is so educated I've
never heard of the story of the pit
bulls for sure I was like and I was I
think I was doing something else like I
couldn't at the moment Google what a pit
bull was and so I was like okay well I
guess you know he just knows things I
don't and then I just moved a birthday
and then I saw the tweet the next day I
was like that's just amazing and that's
what it's like to be an influencer right
you just you just invent words and then
it exists yeah everybody's really into
pickles now it's the whole thing
everybody's very excited about them okay
so dear Hank and
Jessica and Edward sorry we have a theme
song now apparently we're like the three
amigos dear Hank and Jessica and Edward
I have a bit of a dilemma after my high
school graduation my grandmother and I
went out so she could buy me a nice
watch
I've had that watch for almost a year
now but I don't wear it all the time she
always asked me about it when I don't
wear it to which I respond that I didn't
think to put it on however I have my
eyes set on a SmartWatch an Apple watch
to be more specific my question is
should you purchase something that is an
upgrade of a gift someone got for you
best Xavier Oh certainly he is the best
of all hubby this is very hard because
now your grandma's gonna see you wearing
a watch that's not the watch and you
can't be like well I just didn't think
to put a watch on I did and it was a
different one cuz the one you got me
let's be honest grandma it has no idea
what my heart rate is this is another
good person all of these people are so
concerned with other people it's that's
amazing I this is where we queue the
ocean's 11 music because I have the
exact way you do this whole thing all
remin never is the way Oh No okay you
ready okay this this this heist requires
three tools it requires a fancy box it
requires a nice suit and it requires a
account on whatever social media network
your grandmother's on probably Facebook
okay well obviously she's on a social
media account well if not you can work
this like send out a family newsletter
whatever you got to do somehow you have
the paste in this card exactly you're
gonna get this in front of grandma's
eyes one way or the other here's how it
works the first thing you do is you get
up dressed up in the nice suit you put
on grandma's watch and you pose in a
photo that really features the watch you
know like you count like checking the
time or something and then you on social
media you caption it was something like
looks like it's time for an outing this
evening something whatever yeah you're
really playing up the lot okay
you make you know they have to be cheesy
I say go hardcore grandmas don't always
get irony you got it you got to go
hardcore you got to make it clear that
you're loving the watch okay now
after that you take the fancy box you
put grandma's watch in the fancy box you
set it on your dresser or wherever you
want
from that point on by your Apple watch
and then the next time grandma asks hey
where's the watch I got you what's that
watch where's the watch I got you it oh
grandma I only wear that for special
occasions that's good that's good I'm
not gonna lie to everyone yeah and maybe
and maybe like once a year twice a year
do another nice watch shot examine wear
it to Christmas dinner and then after
that George Clooney drives up you get in
the van and you all get away scot-free
that's that's the ocean literally the
best advice whatever is it on this
podcast right there it happened yeah I
can't top that and it was a lie it was
all about constructing a beautiful lie I
will warn against doing this all the
time because then again you're going to
end up no you're gonna end up with so
many things that you don't want they
just sit on your dresser at some point
you have to be willing to tell somebody
like I loved it for a year and now I'm
moving on right it is the hardest thing
in the world to like give away like to
when you're when you're clearing out
clutter it's easy to be like oh I don't
know what I was thinking when I bought
this that's going in the trash but you
come across something that somebody
bought you and you're like oh my god
like I have to keep this forever right
like isn't that the rule if they are
ever gonna be at my house again or see
me like I have to have it there you're
saying Xavier needs to break up with his
grandmother's watch no I'm saying I'm
saying okay grandmother's watch like
this is this sounds like a very special
thing maybe not with that but with other
things you have to be willing to get rid
of stuff that people gave you as a gift
and that was a lesson that it took me
like a decade of collecting water to
figure out like right you have to be
able to do it Marie Kondo has a really
great technique for this she she she
does the air she wrote the book the
life-changing magic of tidying up and
the way that she thinks of it is this
gift had a purpose right it brought you
joy at the time that the person gave it
to you you you received it you enjoyed
it if at this point it doesn't bring you
joy anymore if you look at it and you
feel guilty every time you don't do
something with it
like maybe not a watch but like you know
the little I don't know the weird
unicorn head that sits on your desk and
you
paper clips on but you don't actually
use paper clips and it's just really
cluttering up your desk at some point
you go is this serving me anymore is
this bringing me joy and if the answer
is no you and this is where it gets a
little weird but she actually treats it
like an animate object and she'll thank
it she'll thank it for what it brought
to her life at the time that she got it
and she'll let it go mm-hmm and it
actually works it sounds crazy but it
works yes I have a question about this
is is the Marie Kondo method is part of
the free condo method that Marie Kondo
will come to your house and explain to
your grandmother why you're not wearing
her grandma's might be exempt from this
particular grammars are fairly immune to
Marie Kondo and her wiles I don't know I
kind of want to tweet at her now and be
like what would you do in this situation
how do you not break your grandma's
heart the maze-like
I get the watch of course with them with
the main main thing to avoid here in all
grandma related gift things is you don't
want your grandma to think that you now
want a collection of something because
like if you say like I love that so much
and then suddenly it's like well every
Christmas and birthday from now on
you're getting that one thing over and
over again
you didn't be very clear that this watch
is the special one watch and you're not
a new like convert to having lots of
different special watches you just want
one special dressing-up watch now that's
a really good point yet some people end
up with like an entire turtle collection
or a penguin collection because like one
year the turtle collection there's
nothing wrong with turtles all the way
down or you could get an absolutely
remarkable thing which comes out
September 25th and is available for
pre-order now hey I didn't even come up
with that idea for the gift cards
anytime anybody asked me what they
should get for gifts actually a book is
almost always a good gift like they're
they're they're like a reasonably priced
thing that also like is fairly easy to
pass on to someone else whether that's
like a used bookstore who might give you
credit we got some good ones those in
Missoula here I don't know if
everybody's got those or donating to a
library or to
the people who you know schools and
stuff I think I feel like I feel like
having a new book in your life is never
a bad thing and also they look really
nice in your house and I think
especially in hardcover you guys and you
never have to wear them on your person
so no one will ever ask you what
happened to that book I gave you
that's right you never supposed to like
walk around with a book strapped to your
wrist that doesn't make any sense unless
it's a really good clock book with this
podcast it's actually this podcast
sponsor so I feel bad that I said that
this is a bad idea but this podcast is
brought to you by wrist books it's the
new strap or book to your wrist and then
it's a book on your wrist this podcast
is brought to you by Grimm's fairy tales
aka bedtime warnings portions of this
broadcast were supported by the purple
Council when you think purple think
purple broadcast is brought to you by
artisanal diapers our teas Andale
diapers handcrafted by small women who
work all day to make the perfect diaper
that you will useful one time because it
got full of poop brought to you by the
small women of Artesia labor yeah tell
me more about Artesia okay you guys I'll
I don't know what it is but they're
making so much stuff now I think they
got us beat on trade
yeah the trade surplus to Artesia is
massive you got well they're gonna build
us such a wall so we also you do a very
specific thing on YouTube with the how
to 8-hd so we reached out to Twitter and
also got some questions specific to your
areas of expertise first one we're gonna
ask here is from Brianna who asks what
are your favorite ways to remember to
take your medication I'm currently using
an app that reminds me and yet I still
missed days this also is for me because
I take a lot of pills and have for a
long time but you guys what do you think
I mean the the foolproof way is to put
the pills in in a pill box thing at the
beginning of the week and that way if
Monday is empty you've already taken it
but I've heard
they're really good ways to where some
people will put their pill bottle upside
down when they've taken their pill and
so if their pill bottles still
right-side up they know that they
haven't taken it yet the tricky thing is
you have to remember to put it the other
way again I guess the next day there
have been times when I've had to count
my pills so like I take them every day
so I will actually count out the pills
if it's toward the especially if it's
toward the the end of the month I'll be
like okay know that I only had like two
left and now do I have to or do I have
one I'm not great at this actually to be
honest some days I'll be like Edward did
I take my medicine and he'll be like yes
or no and and I don't know he's better
about knowing that I do but actually my
my best tip now that that works for me
is I also have to take birth control and
so I will know if I took my medicine if
the birth control for that day is empty
that's good because I take them at the
same time in that same way I try and tie
it to another activity that I'm
definitely gonna do every day and do it
right before that activity and so I know
if I've brushed my teeth so I'll make
sure that I take my pills before I brush
my teeth every time and if I'm going to
go brush my teeth and I haven't taken my
pills like I like I formed that habit
that pills then brush teeth and then
like did I take my pills
well my mouth doesn't smell like poop so
yes that's really smart I was really sad
that's actually the best one I've ever
heard so congratulations also
congratulations on brushing your teeth
every day yeah that's hard enough as it
is oh yeah I'm I'm a toothbrush erm and
I'm a tooth pressure I'm really I'm
really worried about AB John has had so
many tooth problems I'm very concerned
about going through that wait who has
tooth problems my brother John Oh John
oh yes no that's right he has he's had
he's he just talks about I was gonna say
how do you know John the dental history
like I understand Hank knowing but what
have you there on the internet I don't
know if you know they talk about their
things sometimes they you say you don't
have time to help I'm just saying I'm
just saying if you have time to know how
no John's dental history you have time
to help me clean the house search it's
all research that's what I told the
judge yeah so Melissa asks if you made
it into adulthood adults lessons yes I
love that term before diagnosis how do
you make up for lost time I'm still
training my parents to take my
neurodiversity seriously how do I
approach future employers or co-workers
etc be upfront conceal fake a chill
exterior in interviews I don't know I've
tried the faking a chill exterior in the
interviews and I just come across like
super awkward I just like learned to
just embrace Who I am and I'm like this
is what you're getting like if you don't
want to work with this like I'll move on
because I'm not gonna fake a chill
exterior every day for the rest of my
life so okay so how do you make up for
lost time yeah this is actually really
common for people who get diagnosed
later in life where they feel like they
missed out they missed a lot of years
and even though I was diagnosed at 12
like I didn't know that you needed more
than medication for a long time and so I
feel like once I realized oh there were
other things that I was supposed to be
getting there were accommodations and
there you know like behavioral therapy
stuff like I should have been getting as
well and so I even felt like I'm just so
far behind like how do I make up for
lost time and there's always a mourning
process that happens where you kind of
have to let that go and say okay well I
was diagnosed now like where do I go
from here we have an episode on on the
channel on youtube.com slash how to eat
each D about being diagnosed as an adult
and somebody who's now an amazing ADHD
coach talked about it talked about the
whole experience of getting diagnosed as
an adult I think it's a great video I
definitely recommend watching it and not
just because on my channel I this that
is my story like I was not diagnosed
until I was 35 and there I'm still kind
of sometimes going through that process
of oh man well my life because I could
just count all the near hits that I've
had in my life where I've built myself
up to a certain level and then my brain
would lose interest
even though I want to keep going and I
would just eventually like just drift
away from like one major opportunity to
the next the only thing that gets me
through melissa is
I just like to think of like every
person is has their own circumstances
has their own situation and as such they
are kind of like their own formula like
an algebraic formula and they have to
work themselves out they are solving
themselves over time and you can't you
can't think Oh what if I had found out
earlier because that's not your formula
you're you and B you if you'd not
earlier maybe that that would that would
be somebody else that wouldn't be you so
you're you and here's what you have what
are you gonna do with it from here
yeah and as far as how to approach
future employers and like whether to
tell them or not it really depends on
your own personal comfort level you do
have some protections because it is
considered a disability if you want to
reveal too like the HR department that
you have ADHD you can also ask for
accommodations which you don't have to
be like hey I have a disability I need
accommodations you can go and say like
hey I have ADHD this is what it means
for me these are a few things that I
personally struggle with and these are
things that help me work at my best like
if I can wear headphones or if I can
have an office where I'm not facing you
know the water cooler and like hearing
everybody talk or wear whatever it is in
the interview that can be once you got
the job right yeah technically you can't
even get accommodations like especially
if you're dealing with something like
dyslexia you can get accommodations even
during the interview process if you want
to have like a verbal test rather than a
written test you can ask for that but it
really depends like most people prefer
not to reveal it until they get the job
but there's two ways you can do it right
you can either let them know I have ADHD
this is what it means for me and these
are some things that would help me or
you can say hey I have challenges with
you know I get distracted if you know if
there's a lot of noise around would you
mind if I wear headphones you don't
necessarily have to reveal the diagnosis
you can just reveal one of the symptoms
that you need help with but yeah it's
just it's a really personal thing but
what I wouldn't count on is anybody
understanding what you're talking about
when you say ADHD because there's yeah
you have to let them know what it is and
how it's affecting you because most
people think oh well isn't that the
thing where like kids are just bouncing
off the walls and don't do well in
school and you have to be like no
actually you know there's the
inattentive presentation
if you have that like you know I
actually am NOT going to be bouncing off
the walls or like you know I don't need
a stranger in my office
unless your job is like trampoline
tester in which case I will be bouncing
every day sir our last question from
Twitter comes from Haneen who asks how
do I deal with my sister's mood swings
due to her ADHD she gets very anxious
and sometimes I don't know what to do
other than hug her until she's calmed
down
are there any coping mechanisms that I
can share with her oh that's a good one
first awesome on you for understanding
that the mood swings are due today ADHD
because not a lot of people know there
is emotional dysregulation that's a
major part of ADHD and most people don't
know that I didn't know that I haven't
eat yeah I didn't know that until I
started doing the research so awesome
and ah you're such a good sister she
gets very anxious sometimes I don't know
what to do other than a hug her I mean
whatever works for her it's gonna be
different for everybody but yeah it can
just be helpful to give somebody their
space as far as coping mechanisms
there's there's depending on how old she
is like behavioral therapy or cognitive
behavioral therapy can help her learn to
deal with that one of the best coping
mechanisms is just to breathe like teach
her breathing techniques and meditation
can help ya mindfulness and meditation
can help a lot too there's not called
headspace that that can teach you how to
meditate even if you have ADHD because
they're very short sessions and they
walk you through it's really really easy
meditation is kind of something that
most people with ADHD are like allergic
to when they first hear it because they
think you have to sit still and like
clear your mind but that's not what
meditation is like I'll fidget sometimes
during meditation and that's okay and
like my mind is very rarely clear I
heard a great thing actually and yoga
today the teacher said meditation is not
so you can control your mind it's so you
can not let your mind control you so
you're still gonna have these thoughts
that like flow in and out of your brain
but you don't have to chase after them
like you can start learning to let those
thoughts go so yeah I definitely
recommend meditation for people with
ADHD and also movement is so helpful for
people with ADHD whether it's deal
with emotional dysregulation or
impulsivity or hyperactivity like moving
I saw the meme I'm giving I'm seriously
like I usually do a lot of research
right now I'm quoting a meme I'm
seriously doing this right now
but movement stills the ADHD mind I am
never as much at peace as when I'm going
on a walk or a run or whatever like
sitting still I can just stew right but
yeah I also throw in bottles great yeah
calming bottles yeah sorry calming
bottles yeah yeah depending on her age
I'm looking at what this is because I've
never heard of it it's really cool it's
essentially like a like a like a plastic
bottle that you put I think you put
water and there's some other fluids as
well or just water there's clear glue
water and glitter that's right and you
shake it up really hard and so it's like
turmoil right and then like a snow globe
kind of thing you watch the glitter
settle and as the glitter settles it
actually calms down your nervous system
you're you're literally watch it's
almost like watching a physicalized
representation of your own anxiety
slowly coming to rest it's really nice
all right you guys let's do one more
question before we wrap it up this one's
from Brian who asks dear Hank and
Jessica and Edward I in the event that I
become famous someday should I have an
autograph that's different from my
signature and if so what are the
different criteria for an autograph
versus a signature this is very
important question for which I required
dubious advice as I'm not clairvoyant
and therefore have no idea whether or
not I will be famous someday Brian well
I think they're the same thing but I
also think that preparing to be famous
one day is a bad plan it is not gonna be
like what you think it is gonna be like
no yeah their turns out there's a lot
more to it than autographs like
autographs are the least of most people
whose famous concerns okay can I just
say that when I I will say to Brian's
question directly yes please do your
autograph separately cuz I didn't know
that and I just was signing my check
signature for awhile like when I first
started just every time
is there a dip was that I totally signed
my check signature we might have to cut
this this question out of the podcast if
that's
yeah I mean I said my check signature
Edward is really cautious I only have
the one signature you guys don't you
have like a 10 minute video if you just
signing it over and over again that's
like no forger has ever been given so
much research material I don't feel I
don't feel like the signature is that
all an important part of the security
mechanisms of a check anymore
but maybe it no it's really not like you
can you can sign anything like they
don't care anymore unless like maybe if
it's your last will and testament
they'll be like this is actually a
signature but yeah for most most things
I don't think they care anymore okay
well that explains why I did not
experience that after I took a film on
tour I I will uh I will give you advice
for in case you become famous someday
whatever the signature is that you use
make it short because your hand will get
very very tired if you get really like
Disney elaborate with it and also don't
try to be famous someday because that
it's super it's just it will eat you in
your heart don't do that just just go
fine just find something you really love
and just do it a lot and you'll be
famous where you won't be it doesn't
matter you'll you'll have a great time
that's all good thing I want to do is
there's all kinds of great ways to be I
think there's all kinds of great ways to
be a well-known and supported or not and
whatever whatever you end up doing but I
think it turns out that the people I
know who are happiest in their a success
are famous not with the whole world but
with a small group of people who are
cool and that's the way to do it it's
like my I have a friend who is a
somewhat famous lepidopterist which is
like people who study butterflies but
only if you're like a lepidopterist only
if you're like really into butterflies
do you know who this guy is
and he's very happy in his world writing
butterfly books and chasing butterflies
and talking about butterflies with
butterfly people it sounds lovely no
that is the best way to because it's the
kind of famous where you you can go
someplace if you need like validation
that day like you go to a butterfly
convention and like everybody loves you
and then you're walking down the street
just having dinner with like a new girl
that you're not sure you want to tell
your parents about yet and you don't
have to worry about paparazzi telling
them for you that's true you just have
to be careful that the butterflies go
that's the only butter vein concern that
would be difficult to explain to your
date there's there is a PS it says I
thought of this question because I
watched Hanks 15 minute video where he
signed pages for his book and absolutely
remarkable thing which comes out
September 25th and is available for
pre-order now and by the way if you want
to get a signed edition they are there's
a limited number of signed copies I just
got news actually that they're running
low on Amazon some of the other
bookstores have more and they will also
be available at physical bookstores when
they come out so we set aside a bunch to
go into physical bookstores but if you
want to get one on the internet you
might want to do that soon because it
sounds like they might actually not be
available on the internet because
there's only I can't I can only do a
certain number because it turns out my
signature is pretty long it was a huge
mistake but thank you thank you Brian
for the promotional opportunity and
thank you Edward for reminding me of it
hey you guys this has been a great
podcast I really enjoyed it usually we
end with news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon but obviously we did a
different thing today because we are
gonna put this one in the can and have
it come out late but thank you for
recording so that we can be ready for
all of the future outages that we will
have but you guys tell me what we
learned today
if you remember at all we learned that
purple has an advocacy group we learned
that you can in fact order artisanal
diapers apparently that's a thing that's
true yes that's true and and they come
from Artesia and we learned that maybe
everybody has a vegan grandma who's
gonna get really offended by your steak
purchases and finally we learned that
you can learn how to do absolutely
anything on wikiHow
such as write a song about wikiHow if
you'd like that's Metta writing at
writing a song about wikiHow you're
using wiki yeah as soon as we end the
podcast he gets to it first he's like
yeah wiki how about wiki how I'll call
I'll call it wiki what oh god this is
actually I think I make do this I think
this this might be my whole wait wait
wait if you're gonna talk about wiki how
Edward on a game that gamma phi is Wiki
Wikipedia yeah that's true he has a
child she do have a child as well we
should not do this thing it's called the
wiki game if you look for it it's
basically it's you trying to connect to
disparate subjects in the shortest
number of steps as fast as you can
through Wikipedia it's it's insanely
addicting and all the ads get goes
directly to Wikipedia man this week
he'll article on how to write a song
it's great so many good illustrations of
people who seem like they're just having
a great time by fret living with
themself or with friends this one has a
really weird this was a bunch of musical
notes on this one except there's one
giant hook I don't know is that oh it's
about the hook you got to look for the
hook Oh anyway
anyway that's my that's my vlogbrothers
video let's not talk about it because I
don't want to spoil everybody or you
just have to you have to call it wiki
wiki what oh and even better if you use
even even better if you use the how to
write a love song that's the what I use
it was fantastic how to write a love
song specifically wiki has a video right
there it's yeah it does alright you guys
thank you this is a pleasure this
podcast is produced by rosianna halse
rojas and Sheridan Gibson it's edited by
nicholas jenkins our head of community
and communications is victoria bon
giorno the music the jeering now and at
the end of the episode Oh at the
beginning of the episode is by the great
gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]